oh [ __ ] we're already already going yeah
okay and performance and go Thanks no no
I feel about when you put your hand you
know what you do with that hand right
it's awful he's saying you jerk off no
well it's you know other people too you
jerk off other people too la la you know
I might you're out here once and it just
goes the damn [ __ ] it'll come from
Idaho you come to LA Oh
hand job me guys on us look how host
what baby red you're gonna be doing it
soon too
mister hey I pay my dues that a don't
remind me anyway guys I'm Ryan right I'm
Kent syverud take a better you
so Jacob is new to the channel he's
dance childhood friend he's visiting so
we were like why not come on we're just
buddies here we're not professional
filmmakers don't force it know what
feelings it's gone it's gone so well and
you really pushing it hard nah I was
impressed I can bring him around more oh
okay yeah so that's the first day that
we're watching it it uh though if we
sell depor we that's what we're gonna
watch today Zelda for Wii U it's excited
about Zelda you're if you're a gamer too
right pretty much okay so you grew up
like playing Zelda and all that yes I
did
oh yeah we we spent many hours sunk into
Zelda games especially on a Super
Nintendo oh yeah I feel comfortable
being in between YouTube yeah it's like
blue its Wars bromance nothing right
here like all right give the bro man you
gotta intercepted this is all sandwich
yes yeah I do love Zelda actually it's
one of the few games I am very familiar
with not gonna say the last one I play
because you know ii like you could play
like 15 [ __ ] zelda games but if you
didn't play number sixteen through like
you're not a real self and you suck
queer is something like really insulting
there so anus yeah so yeah I'm not gonna
say the last when I play but it wasn't
the last one that came out I'll tell you
that much have you seen this trip yeah I
have seen this trailer okay so I'm here
more for adding
contexts this is have you seen it no I
that's what we need Dan someone who
hasn't seen the [ __ ] trailer alright
let's check out this real
[Music]
last year I said that revisiting the
conventions of the Zelda series would be
our theme for the new Zelda game for we
yelled however before I get into that
let me talk about something that I
needed to help to realize your ambition
in fact it's something that we've wanted
to do for a long time in the Legend of
Zelda series and so development began
with this as our focus in the earlier
releases of The Legend of Zelda games
players got to explore a wide area
scrolling up down left and right
however after the game transition to 3d
and the hardware continued to evolve it
became harder to create that feel of
being in a fast world for example in the
Wind Waker we used various techniques to
create a wide world where you could
freely explore many isolated islands but
it was very hard to create one large
world where everything felt connected we
had to design small bounded areas with a
defined entrance and exit and putting
them all together made it feel like you
were playing in a large world throughout
you'd always think I da so I'm gonna
meet Dinah Kahn's really cool I just
don't even cut through the boundaries
where ever you like to explore that
stuff that you don't think about what
today I'd like to talk to everyone about
the latest Zelda game for Wii U but
first please take a look at how the game
looks on screen wow this is the new
world of Zelda yes it's quite a vast
world isn't it oh geez what you can even
reach those mountains in the distance
if you walk far enough we couldn't
create such a wide world like this in
the past as far as what you can do with
such a vast field to explore as soon as
those boundaries are removed it means
you can enter any area from any
direction so the puzzle solving in this
game begins the moment the player starts
to think about where they
go how they will get there and what they
will do when they arrive this is a clean
break from the conventions of past games
and Zelda series where you had to follow
a set path and play through the scenario
in the right order I believe this
departure will create opportunities for
new gameplay that have not been
experienced in previous Elder games as
you can see and as you know from the
Zelda series the world in these games
can be quite peaceful however it is a
Zelda game after all so strong enemies
will certainly appear even this several
powerful enemies appearing in such a
peaceful world is one of the defining
features of it was a nice ride
[Music]
Wow you know what
this is equally
ah I've got chills nipples erect right
now all the explanation about what they
want to deal with the zones it just
makes that moment so much better yeah
that's actually one of the best teasers
I've ever seen I'm gonna buy a Wii you
know yeah right now you work I'm doing
it now it's on the list it's really not
prior I was not playing I'm gonna go
with you
okay I know about one gun that's all it
takes for me really oh yeah your
decision maker man yeah that's crazy one
I go with my heart and his heart says
well Zelda for Wii U and apparently
laser arrows I mean come on
that was incredible that that looks
awesome yeah these all the games always
tend to deliver man was there ever a bad
Zelda game it's um it's only bad in
comparison with itself
what Majora's oh don't say that the
internet y-you know the internet will
hate you go ever see him again you know
what you guys are talking about so well
oh wait that was when they came after
ocarina of time yes that's right mmm it
was a waste of time
mmm according to maybe someone on the
other end of the couch oh I get it out
he doesn't like it but a lot of people
do the Internet is going gosh yeah I get
it I get it
enjoy this comment section well yeah now
that game does look cool I especially
liked how they compared it to the older
Zelda which makes it look that much more
fascinating like the first Zelda
literally just kind of like drops you in
the middle of nowhere it says okay go
that's sort of been missing in the Zelda
franchise for a while it's starting
become a little more like okay go here
go here go here especially with Skyward
Sword which was very much like drop in
here do the mission here and then go
back out drop to the next area so it
will be really cool to kind of see just
how expansive they decided to do
like make this world what I really liked
to was how they they were saying how you
can choose any path and this time around
you know like that's cool you to really
explore himself it's not Hyrule again is
it so it's high roll till we Tyra Harlan
always there's definitely no better
genre of a game to have such a vast open
world in than I think though yes yes so
true
absolutely so true a monsters the
dungeons just everything being able to
just go out there and just see every
nook and cranny is going to be amazing
alright guys well if you're new to the
channel you can click here to subscribe
and if you want to subscribe to dance
channel if you want to it's right here
please do that cyber Channel mm-hmm and
um you can catch you're gonna be on it
right I'll probably still be there so
you guys can come Yelp me there for the
majora's man yeah great awesome can't
wait to sit through those subscribe yell
at Dan and I'm out I'll see you as well
so can you can feel the friendship
between a tune I really like it it's you
know the rare chemistry it's good for
Cameron who's gonna increase views to
cheap money click on those advertisement
so one's gotta pay the bill friend and
my new friend we play we do shout outs
at the end of these videos ok yeah so
we're gonna shout some noise out one
person I keep forgetting a shout out or
Luke how boats haboos something like
that this guy's been asking for a shout
for a long time he's really waited that
endurance persistence patience that you
have developed over this shout out is
inspiring Luke that's a good speech that
is it bout something that I was really
impressed myself just now I was inspired
now honestly I was if I follow you in
the depths of hell it's already brought
like I have the swords I'm like shields
we're ready to go let's do it
good shot well Luke you deserve the best
Lukey boy
the next person des Christophe yo I
recently said if you gave me a shout-out
I'm sorry I didn't notice because you're
way too awesome that doesn't make sense
but I'm giving you a shout-out right now
that's what counts
des Christophe it's so awesome that now
it's in your face boom emcees it is he
looks like Filipina uh he's coming on my
stuff before I agent some type of Asian
he wears a hood who wears a hood can't a
guy with a hood can't choice a guy with
a hood that way to sleep alright ride
with me what's he what's he doing I
don't know it's been a long [ __ ] week
for me my god
he's have a log I don't understand the
bit I don't know he's wearing a hood and
just drop it it was a failed joke just
kind of work off your material des sorry
man I edit this out ex Levithan x15 oh I
didn't see ya Leviathan shall please I'm
a big fan by the way if you give me a
shout-out you can call me Noah or sweet
daddy
because I know my youtube name is hard
to say Tim right it is suppose I read
the comic before you catch that eye as
well well sweet daddy Noah
here's your shout-out buddy you deserve
this shadow earned it earned it yeah you
have earned you earned three little bit
mm-hmm you actually earned it this time
that's great you didn't just ask there's
a lot of people that just kind of expect
things and you went out of your way and
really made this special yeah I'm
graduation sweet daddy hmm
so Dan calls hanjo friends sweet day no
that's what happens during your the
mutual friend man you're gonna get back
time that's him it's okay Dan it's for
survival right sometimes you guys I
would copy sometimes you gotta do a hand
over to you to make it out of the woods
five and job dan that's what they call
that should be your YouTube me [ __ ] both
that cyber candy is a bird head job Jim
god dammit I knew this was a bad idea
the moment I said yes you're over Jake